l'équivalent du pib de la tunisie
elon musk et 36 milliards en un jour a
posé une question à vous poser une
question fiscale admet ce qui a touché
36 milliards en un jour non les réponses
est l'équivalent du pib de la tunisie
qui a touché l'eau de masques en un jour
exactement combien ils osent musk at il
gagné en 24 heures et ouais et il a
passé une bonne journée celui-ci il est
officiellement devenu l'homme le plus
riche de la planète avec une fortune
estimée par bloomberg à 289 milliards de
dollars ah ouais ouais c'est ouf en un
jour le patrimoine du fondateur de tesla
a fait un énorme bond c'est du jamais vu
ça a fait un bond de 36 2 milliards de
dollars ça représente 31 2 milliards d'
euros ou en dollars on prend aussi à
regarder
aujourd'hui que le prix de la baguette
forme complètement plus 10 centimes sur
la baguette fac à 10 centimes
supplémentaires il donnera à qui ça
devrait pas poser beaucoup de problèmes
elon musk désormais il est très loin
devant les autres grandes fortunes
mondiales 1,289 milliard de dollars et
oui il a carrément gagné 36 milliards de
dollars juste lundi avec sa marque de
voitures électriques
ou prenez donc en un seul jour le gagner
tranquillement de quoi s'acheter 31
milliards de baguettes 28 millions de
smartphones dernier cri 172 qui viennent
m ba bê et malheureusement qu'un seul
t-shirt du dressing de guillaume genton
qui restent inabordables même port et
donne sa très belle pièce
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que vous seriez
plus heureux avec 36 milliards de
dollars dit la vérité cast a dit oui
vraiment ah oui vraiment penser que
l'argent rues larges en fait il fait
beau nord ah ouais non mais c'est fou ça
vous kelly non non franchement je pense
pas merci en tout cas pour votre réponse
non parce que ça me gênerait je
culpabiliserai je donnerai tout je ne
serai pas qu'ils donnaient pas castaldi
vous non plus moi l'argent je m'en fous
complètement à voir donc fou pour être
heureux c'est delphine
[Musique]
et mon prix inestimable
à la
tête de ma mère ils vont primer
baltes et non plus non parce que les
choses que j'aime n'ont pas de prix ou
du moins où un prix très moi j'adore me
promener en forêt j'adore
me l'acheter la forêt
si j'étais millionnaire ça me changerait
rien d'accord peut-être que je prendrais
plâtre chien je réussis à c'est tout et
je ferai en franchement à bernard
montiel oui hein c'est castaldi bernard
montiel on voit c'est vraiment les deux
amants on voit qui est des deux côtés je
donne rien à personne 0
je garde tout je ne veux rien on sera
difficile avait l'argent c'est un père
ses dictateurs après sa mort la vie pas
l'argent comme ça nous donne pas la
santé ça nous donne pas l'amour sur
ça facilite énormément les choses et je
pense que si on a beaucoup d'argent
comme bill gates on peut donner plein de
bonheur ont perçu un truc super bien et
donc pardon mais bravo non non c'est
très bien d'avoir plus c'est pas nul
hein ce qui est bien c'est pas nul oui
c'est pas nul franchement c'est pas nul
est votre point de vue cyril sur quoi
sur l'oseille
alors je vais vous dire moi je m'en fous
totalement de l'argent c'est vrai mais
vraiment jamais été un moteur pour vous
jamais
l'auteur alors un moteur c'est pas de
l'essence pour vous la barre alors moi
c'est moi c'est ma musique maintenant
excusez moi benjamin vous ne trouvez pas
parce que là maintenant je mette les
choses ne pouvaient pas indécent de
poser cette question à quelqu'un qui
vous fait vivre nourri à centimes
laurier dans le caniveau
[Musique]
respecter l'eau non non mais alors
d'abord je laime d'amour nos meilleures
si mauvais pas faux ce que tu dis oui
mais ça m'intéresse sa réponse non mais
c'est vrai moi c'est moi ce qui compte
pour moi c'est la dar k voilà ce
maintien ça c'est vrai voilà maintenant
avec un petit bémol est très riche aussi
on crée aussi beaucoup d'emplois et
c'est un super gratifiant
l'adar cas c'est le plus important j'ai
vraiment fait la gazette dans la cua
banon at war moi je vais vous dire j'ai
toujours fait des requins voyez vous
êtes dans la barca ou penone 50% de ce
que vous avez
vous dire que j'ai peur que je ne sois
plus du tout dans le nord car c'est le
problème que sa plus grande richesse
c'est aimer et être aimé bama la perte
de richesse et que tu fermes ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est une belle richesse il a demandé
à la publicité si vous pouvez vous
donner un million chacun bah oui là on
est combien on est neuf autour de cette
table où ils sont trop mignons genève
ots mignon c'est une énorme barca
excusez moi mouais
si la
loi vous avez d'autres idées vous
m'appelez
vous verrez je vous répondrai pas merci
à les réponses à bastien c'est ce que je
vais vous donner un 5 à 10 centimes
5 à 10 centimes aux qualités quelle est
la prochaine augmentation de benjamin
nom
qu'elle a été l'augmentation de la
baguette de pain voilà elle est devenue
dizaine de la mairie
ce regain delphine wespiser elle part en
cacahuète diouf dont combien le prix de
la baguette va-t-il augmenter de 5 à 10
centimes c'est vrai que moi je jouais là
quel point tous les jours ah oui vous
savez ça a pris la baguette c'est un
euro ouais ouais ça dépend à 90 centimes
donner un crédit sont 1 0 sané pour vous
êtes bien renseigné 90 centimes d'euro
pour une tradition je vais acheter le
pain tous les jours et le comex et vous
quel est à votre sens bien sûr qu'après
man 10 centimes à tradition nonchalant
une boulangerie nature mais en annonçant
qu'elle boulangerie mais moi j'ai un
prix déjà
j'ai un prix déjà jolie attention c'est
la presser autour de 1 euro 20 si je
puis me permets nolasco j'attends les
supérettes où il va dans les supérettes
et
valait pas la super et demi
je vais la super et
la supérette c'est un collage et
carrefour market voilà
à côté de chez williams qu'à
quelques encablures
voilà et je fais des rockers fonderie et
j'adore me promener et acheter les
choses avec un guerrier un vous voyez
afrique a dit exactement un fauteuil
prochaine fois bien sûr je veux faire
une photo ap ap une fois mes bras
s'est sérieusement
[Rires]
c'est que j'ai pris pour augmenter à
cause d'une hausse généralisée des
charges la raison principale est
l'envolée du cours du blé qui a pris 30%
depuis le début de l'année le blé flambe
qui pourrait vous coûter plus cher de 5
à 10 centimes en raison de la hausse des
prix 15 % pour la farine et 30 % pour le
blé mais pas prêt à se passer de la
baguette les français sont prêts à payer
et ça paraît naturel
vous êtes travaillé touché absolument
parce que le fait un bond si le prix de
la baguette est une référence pour
calculer le coût de la vie selon lindsay
en vingt ans il a augmenté de 23
centimes
alors y'a pas que ça je voulais pas que
ça mais pris la baguette non c'est
important effectivement il ya le blé
mais il ya surtout l'électricité qui a
augmenté aussi
l'électricité a augmenté quant à lui
cheikh il faut bien les cuire à bien sûr
c'est donc ce électricité par exemple ah
oui t'es pas content non c'est rien mais
si c'est sérieux je m'en fous je
comprends je n'étais pas content mais
c'est vrai oui moi je serais pour que le
prix de la baguette soit bloqué fixé
pourquoi parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
qu'en france les grandes révoltes sont
venus parce que le pain est déterminante
celle ci serait émis mais une baguette
de pain vous 10 centimes tous les jours
pour des familles ça fait un budget donc
vraiment je serai pourquoi la moins de
quoi j'en ai déjà un marché mondial le
blé je sais je pars dans un monde idéal
on devrait bloquer voilà parfois des
réponses galoche gallo très lâche mais
castaldi qu'est-ce que n'aura jamais
lieu avec des ballades pas mal vous avez
tous éviter tout
ce qui va se passer entre delphine et
moi dans un futur très proche
futur très proche et moins de 20 ans
avant noël galoche ça parle d'une
émission oui
quel est le nouveau passe temps de
nabila et magana mon
nom à l'histoire rien des galoches
bagasse galoche ouais c'est chouette
voit les deux ouais les deux miles vague
à l'âme et nabila semaine alors à
tétouan vraiment pas vu ça
oui ben oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans l'amour et dans le privé vieira
bravo à bravo bravo bravo guillaume
genton bassin café un agriculteur pour
la première fois hier il a galoche on a
une bonne nouvelle hervé qui est un peu
le tanguy de cette nouvelle saison a
enfin pecho bravo à lui regarde et lui
s'étaient mis en grève
vous
[Musique]
m
ça fait du bien c'est calme
[Musique]
bagis croyez plus
j'ai tellement souffert que
je me disais c'est pas possible ça
m'arrive un taux
mais si j'étais là j'adore
ces beaux ratés la société on voit que
première garage castaldi l'az en 13 ans
c'est hyper tôt bah oui c'est ça ben oui
oui vous 15 ans ah oui
qu'est ce qui vous étonne ce que vous
vouliez dire je voulais dire que cette
scène m'a choqué
[Applaudissements]
asnières d'anti sens là j'ai regardé
l'émission de la manière dont ils
s'embrassent comment s'est montrée en
gros plan comme ça c'est alors il est
dit que ce qui est bon diby sionisme et
ça marche t'aimes pas l'amour d'aller
dans la galerie
organique et tu veux
de choquant deux personnes qui s'aiment
sincèrement qu'ils sont en train de
brûler et qu'ils sont en train de
s'embrasser pour à preures voit de là
haut niveau ce monsieur c'est la
première fois qu'il embrasse une femme
l'émotion là où on la ressent chez nous
il ya quad et dégradants en fait c'est
beau pour danser de l'exhibition
télévisuelle au labo je trouvais ça
super beau mais effectivement on voit
que c'est la première fois on voit le
même d'un galop alors toi tais toi je
sais que tu es dans un truc de galop
comme ça avec des robots avec guillaume
j'ai l'impression pas du tout à l'étroit
je sais plus quoi vous dire à la fin
j'ai dit moins de 10% gedibois dans les
prochaines heures
suivi le galocher s'est trompé ah bah
oui oui bah si parce que vous savez pas
qu'il y avait une question c'est est-ce
que sucer c'est tromper
[Rires]
alors alors ça ça passe quand même
vraiment alors là vraiment on en en
galoche et bien sûr que moi mais tout
est trompé avec moi bah oui bien sûr ah
oui fois c'est si oui ah ouais moi je
suis vraiment si on pose le regard sur
pas quelqu'un d'autre tout d'abord fait
une crise bah ouais moi je savais que ça
c'est vous savez que l'amour ce n'est
pas la propriété c'est on n'est pas
possesseurs de quelqu'un non mais après
après je laisse la personne très libre
ah oui c'est quand je la vois voilà
après comme je la vois une fois sur dix
par sabine s'est pas non plus à la folie
les chéris 117 millions sont 17 h et
samedi s'est installée cette affaire ça
c est ce que mais quel est le quelle est
la somme que mathieu vous a demandé pour
animer ou faux
non non mais sans répit c'est le budget
de mon mariage avec des films
commencent à réfléchir alors combien
kelly doit guillaume genton pour les
achats shopping c'est indécent on va
creuser là quelles subventions karine le
marchand at elle renoncé sous la
pression médiatique voilà c'est
exactement karine le marchand à la suite
du scandale elle renonce à la subvention
de son 17000 euros pour sa maison
secondaire alors karine lemarchand
devait recevoir une subvention de 117
1000 euros pour rénover une bâtisse dans
la région paca s'est fait couler
énormément d'encre et crée une grosse
polémique et du coup l'animatrice de m6
s'est exprimé sur ses réseaux sociaux a
déclaré abandonner cette subvention
regardez parce qu'en fait ça a été une
histoire de fou inter parce qu'en fait
c'est pas ça qui lui a été proposée
c'est qu'elle avait elle est très proche
de la région paca 1 c'est ça et elle est
ambassadrice elle est ambassadrice
exactement la région paca dont il ya
plein de gens connus c'est peut-être un
échange marchandises alors on a avec
nous dans un instant nathalie moreau
porte parole europe ecologie les verts
de la région paca qui va nous raconter
toute cette affaire et va nous raconter
ce qui s'est passé exactement c'est
parti
on connaît tous l'expression on ne prête
qu'aux riches et bien il semblerait que
cette nouvelle affaire confirme la règle
ça commence fort en effet selon marsactu
karine lemarchand animatrice
emblématique de m6 aurait touché de la
part de la région provence alpes côte
d'azur une subvention de 117 1000 euros
pour les travaux de la rénovation de sa
maison de campagne
face à ce scandale naissant l'animatrice
a tenu à s'exprimer ma maison de
production aura l'usufruit de la maison
pendant 15 ans d'ici là elle ne sera pas
à moi je payerai un loyer quand j'irai
de son côté la région a bien communiqué
expliquant que ces subventions étaient
accessibles à tous les particuliers
karine le marchand a obtenu une
subvention de 117 mille euros c'est à
dire 44 27 % du montant des études
dédiées à la rénovation énergétique
alors que le plafond est fixé à 70 % du
montant total comme n'importe quel
particulier face à la polémique karine
le marchand a pourtant tenu à renoncer à
cette subvention s'exprimant sur
instagram avait renoncé à cette demande
et j'aime débrouiller comme une grande
comme sa tournée content la prochaine
fois karine le marchand de vendre un
conseil à son ami stéphane plaza
alors elle a le droit à la veine de
marchands alors bonjour merci d'être
avec nous nathalie moreau porte parole
europe ecologie les verts de la région
paca à la halle a le droit non deux de
mémoire on n'a jamais vu une telle somme
pour ce genre de subventions jamais et
on n'a toujours pas compris les
contreparties à l'argent public et
allaient être utilisés pour rénover ce
qui au final et sa maison à elle puisque
c'est bien son nom du malade il avait
elle avait des projets donc pour faire
des choses dans la production c'est ça
dépend sa maison de production oui c'est
ça exactement c'est ça mais non c'est
une maison qui laissera son nom qui va
être pendant 15 ans l'usufruit de sa
société de production mais en réalité
personne n'a clairement compris et c'est
pour ça que la presse et saisit de la
sphère d'accord personne n'a compris les
contreparties mais pourquoi une telle
samu ont été accordés donc jamais de ces
de ces montants là pour des rénovations
énergétiques
de mémoire jamais quand on dit que
qu'elle a reçu 44 % du montant alors
qu'elle pouvait aller jusqu'à 70% ça
vous dit que non c'est pas vrai je dis
que c'est étonnant qu'ils aient une
telle somme qui était utilisé pour ce
pur pour ça et nous ce qui nous a
vraiment indigné c'est d'ailleurs elle
le dit elle renonce à cet argent parce
qu'elle peut faire autrement et donc en
réaliser cet argent besoin alors
qu'amazon
l'elysée c'est de l'argent pu mal se
doit être réalisé pour les habitants et
les habitants de la région mais autour
la transition énergétique des habitants
et des habitants de la région mais dit
elle a dit qu'elle avait un projet de
transition énergétique dans un mondial
non elle elle avait le droit légitime
homme c'est sa maison de production et
elle devait payer un loyer tous les mois
la bien dit elle était très clair là
dessus maintenant leur nom sus à la
suite à la polémique mais c'est dommage
de la torre gilles verdez elle était
obligée de renoncer ça s'appelle le
domaine des belles âmes ça a été acheté
un million 3 et n'oublions pas que la
somme ces 44 % du montant des études 117
1000 euros ça veut dire que c'est des
études à plus de 250000 euros quelle
propriété nécessite des études comme ça
donc c'était très opaque il y avait deux
personnes qui allaient travailler il ya
5000 mètres carrés de jardin à rénover
c'était tellement opaques elle ne
pouvait pas résister à ça déjà je ne
sais pas pourquoi ça a été votée mais
c'était impossible de garder cette
subvention a été votée je salue le fait
qu'elle soit qu'elles aient renoncé à
cette subvention
c'était vraiment la bonne vision en
réalité ok c'est une victoire pour nous
les écologistes parce que c'est vraiment
une politique bling bling en réalité
c'est une politique bling bling pour des
gens qui n'ont pas besoin on a 40% de
passoires thermiques dans notre région
on a des lycées qui sont vétustes et
l'argent dans la transition énergétique
et doit être remis pour les gens qui en
ont vraiment besoin après elle vous
rénovez elle a parlé de démonstrateurs
pédagogique salon vous parler mais c'est
un masque qui a coûté plus d'un million
d'euros actuels à qui ça va servir comme
exemple
ça sert uniquement à des gens est ce
qu'il est dans la région paca ça sert
uniquement à des gens extrêmement riche
et ça ne permettra pas aux particuliers
je pense par exemple aux gens qui se
retrouvent dans ces passoires thermiques
qui vont sûrement encore cet hiver
devoir renoncer à se chauffer ou mal se
chauffer ça ne leur permettra absolument
pas d'entamer la rénovation thermique la
rénovation énergétique par man dont ils
ont besoin benjamin soit il soit l'oea
droit et voilà contribuer à améliorer
voilà c'est un fait mais apparemment
c'était une bourse ou consommer pourquoi
est-ce que ça vous gêne si pascal et
minutes et c'est inutile et totalement
mais voilà les gars mais où c'est légal
ou pas les buts passés ça régale le fait
que ce soit quelqu'un de connu qui mais
qui bénéficie de subventions bon voilà
avons demandé le retrait nous avons
demandé le retrait de la subvention pour
que l'argent public soit
elles sont toutes les balles vont
demander le retrait nous avons demandé
leur retrait de la subvention à renaud
muselier qui s'apprêtait lui accorder
qui est le président de la région cela
on l'a vu poser avec lui d'ailleurs nous
n'avons rien comme contre madame le
marchand nous c'est nous avons
interpellé la région d'accord je
rappelle que les écologistes se sont
retirés face au danger du rassemblement
national aux dernières élections
régionales et c'est sûrement pas pour
que l'argent public soit utilisé cette
façon donc oui oui boyard devant moi je
trouve ça trop facile de parler de dire
c'est légal déjà parce que ça n'a pas
été une décision de justice en fait
c'est renaud muselier qui a décidé donc
c'est une décision qui est politique est
ce que vous dites est très juste elle en
a les moyens alors que d'autres
personnes juste cet hiver là et c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut organiser
certaines personnes crève de froid quoi
et cet argent là on a si on avait de
l'argent en illimité ok pas de problème
mais là c'est pas le cas donc s'aggraver
dans la voix mais où est passé cet
argent va également étudier c'est ça le
problème j'espère bien après la
polémique qui s'est tapé je devenais
qu'ils mettent les 117 1000 pour aller
aider des familles qui sont en
difficulté mais surtout derrière ils
sont très proches ils sont très amis en
politique il ya quand même une certaine
posture à avoir de a à z ça tient pas
cette affaire de a à z ça tient pas doit
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait dénoncé marsactu
c'est que voilà tout est au conditionnel
ça pourrait servir pour une émission est
en fête et puis il ya eu plein de
versions différentes qui ont été données
par madame le marchand ou par renaud
muselier le président de la région paca
donc enfin en en réalité on n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre pour quelles
raisons
cet argent devait être lui être donnée
donc vous dites que dans son bureau tout
seul renaud muselier a dit je vais
donner cette aide à madame le marchand
comme ça en tête de gondole médiatique
comme ça de la rénovation et je file je
souhaite la question et c'est pour ça
nous devons demander le retrait de la
subvention c'est pour ça que l'après l
ambassadrice de la beauté
c'est parce que on attaque on a pas on à
paris allait elle est rémunérée pour
être ambassadrice dans la région alors
normalement les rires oui oui elle est
rémunérée ou être en baisse à 10
ambassadrices de la région mais les
journalistes n'arrivent pas à savoir
combien mais ça veut dire qu'on basse à
lauris de la région paca c'est ça ne
veut rien dire c'est
rien rice la promotion et
la promotion de la région d'accord je
cite des études ici je mange un pan
bagnat ouais c'est comment il comprend
elle vient d'être engagé donc pour la
cei a aucune action concrète les
journalistes et des journalistes s'ancre
encore en train de se demander combien
les rémunérer et en fait vous madame
côte au conseil pouvait pas demander les
chiffres y a pas d' enquête j'aimerais
pourtant failli puisque je fais partie
des gens qui se sont retirés pour
empêcher voilà
ça n'a rien à voir c'est autre chose
mais vous puisque vous êtes dans la
région paca vous auriez pu demander
c'est énormément en tout cas si
rémunérer la wii permet donc à rien
concédé par rapport aux salaires
l'ambassadrice ça ne s'est pas partie de
ce qui est visible pour l'instant ça
sera accessible plus tard puisqu'il
s'agit il s'agit de ce qui rend dans le
plan média donc c'est uniquement quand
le but en tout cas là elle a bien fait
de rail ne voulait pas faire autrement
oui bah ouais franchement c'est
important qu'elle le fasse